- What is this story
behind this song you're
singing today "Throw Me A Party"?
- Okay, so "Throw Me A Party" I wrote with
the amazing song writers
Liz Rose and Christian Bush
from the band Sugarland.
And a few years ago, you know,
you kinda hear the words
that you never, ever
think you're gonna hear or
that you ever wanna hear,
which is you have cancer.
And I found out that I had breast cancer
and had a bilateral mastectomy,
and I'm a survivor sitting
here today talking to you.
- That's so awesome.
(audience clap and cheer)
- It was so interesting
'cause when you're going
through something like that and you really
don't know what it's going to be like
and how it's gonna turn out,
and you don't know if you're
gonna be sitting here.
- [Kelly] And you have kids.
- And you have kids, and I
wanted to have these very
serious discussions with my
husband and I said to him,
"look if something happens
and I should go before you
"then I just want you to know
"there's a couple of things I want.
"One, I want you to be super
sad for a real long time."
(audience laugh)
- Like, I will hunt you if
you date someone next week.
- Exactly, like I will hunt you.
And then the second things
was that I wanted a party.
I wanted to have a celebration
and I wanted to have a
lot of singing and dancing
and people telling stories,
and to feel like that
was being celebrated.
And so the song came out of that.
I had the title and wrote
it with Liz and Christian.
- [Kelly] It's great.
- Thank you.
- Like I was telling you, I've never heard
a song that I will listen
to all the time like.
And also perfect, there are,
it's a hard thing a funeral,
and I've had to sing at funerals.
I don't know if you've
had to do that before?
It's the worst thing ever.
- No'
- Don't say yes, and it's
just the worst thing ever.
And it should be, sometimes I feel like
we're this culture that
we just get so depressed
by it and it is a very depressing thing.
But at the same time, like celebrate
the life that was lived.
- Exactly.
- And that's what I loved
about the whole lyric.
It was so perfect.
- 'Cause there's gonna be time.
There's gonna be crying and
there's gonna be sadness.
- And that's okay.
- And you never ever
forgot, you know, a person.
You never do.
I think about my mom and
dad every single day.
- [Kelly] And they're in you.
- Exactly.
- They're a part of you.
My five-year-old is literally
learning about death
right now just 'cause
she was seeing something.
I'm like, "you're five."
This is a hard conversation,
but I keep telling her,
I'm like, "even if something
was ever to happen to mommy
"I'm never really gone
because you are in me
"and we're apart of each other."
- Yes.
- And so I'm always present,
and it's like really hard,
you find yourself kind of
talking yourself through death
while you're trying to tell your child.
- That's exactly right.
You're trying to kind
of wrap your head around
your own mortality and
that's the weirdest thing,
but I have to say that in someways,
and I don't know if
there's survivors or people
who have had struggles in the audience
but in someways cancer was a blessing,
like it really taught
me to live every moment
to the fullest and every
moment as if it was your last.
Like we don't know what tomorrow brings.
We have to be able to live
and go out today going,
"wow, okay, I did it.
"I did everything that I wanted to do.
"I lived the life that
I wanted to live today."